for any transformation that maps from
rn
to rn
we've done it implicitly but it's been
interesting for us to find the vectors
that essentially just get scaled up by
the transformations so the vectors that
have the form the transformation of my
vector is just equal to some scaled up
version of the vector and if this
doesn't look familiar i can jog your
memory a little bit
when we were looking for basis vectors
for the transformation let me draw it
this was an from r2 to r2
from r2 to r2 so let me draw r2 right
here
and let's say i had the vector
let's add the vector
let's say v1
was equal to the vector 1 2 and we had
the line spanned by that vector we did
this problem
several videos ago
and i had the transformation that
flipped across this line so if you call
that line l
t was the transformation from r2
to r2
that flipped vectors across this line so
it flipped
flipped vectors
flipped vectors across l
so if you remember that transformation
if i had some random vector that looked
like that let's say that's x that's
vector x then the transformation of x
looks something like this it's just
flipped across that line
that was the transformation of x and if
you remember that video we were looking
for a change of basis that would allow
us to at least figure out the the matrix
for the transformation at least an
alternate basis and then we could figure
out the matrix for the transformation in
the standard basis and the bases we
picked were basis vectors that didn't
get changed much by the transformation
or ones that only got scaled by the
transformation for example
when i took the transformation of v1
when i took the transformation of v1 it
just equaled v1 or we could say
that the transformation of v1 just
equaled 1 times
v1 so if you just follow this
this little format that i set up here
lambda in this case would be one and of
course the vector in this case is v1 the
transformation just scaled up v1 by one
now if you also if you that same problem
we had the other vector that we also
looked at let's say it was a vector
it was the vector
minus let's say it's the vector v 2
which is let's say it's 2
minus 1.
and then if you take the transformation
of it since it was orthogonal to the
line it just got flipped over like that
and that was a pretty interesting vector
for us as well because the
transformation
the transformation of v2
in this situation is equal to what just
minus v2 it's equal to minus v2 or you
could say that the transformation of v2
is equal to
-1 times v2
and these were
interesting vectors for us because when
we defined a new basis with these guys
as the basis vector it was very easy to
figure out our transformation matrix and
actually that basis was very easy to
compute with and we'll explore that a
little bit more in the future
but hopefully you realize that these are
interesting vectors there's also the
cases where we had the planes spanned by
some vectors
and then we had another vector that was
popping out of the plane like that and
we were transforming things by taking
the mirror image across this and we're
like well in that transformation these
these red vectors don't change at all
and this guy gets flipped over so maybe
those would make for good bases or those
would make for good basis vectors and
they did so in general we're always
interested
with the vectors that just get scaled up
by a transformation and not it's not
going to be all vectors right this
vector that i drew here this vector x it
doesn't just get scaled up it just get
it it actually gets changed its
direction gets changed
the the vectors that get scaled up might
switch direct might go you know from
this direction to that direction or
maybe they go from that maybe that's x
and then the transformation of x might
be a scaled up version of x maybe it's
that
but their actual the the the actual uh i
guess a line that they span will not
change and so that's what we're going to
concern ourselves with because these
have a special name and they have the
special name i i want to make this very
clear because they're useful you know
it's not just some mathematical game
we're playing although sometimes we do
fall into that trap but they're actually
useful they're useful for defining bases
because in those bases it's easier to
find transformation matrices they're
more natural coordinate systems and
oftentimes the transformation matrices
in those bases are easier to compute
with
and so these have special names
this any vector that satisfies this
right here is called an eigenvector
eigenvector
for the transformation t
for t
and the lambda the multiple that it
becomes this is the eigenvalue
eigenvalue
associated
with
that eigenvector
so in the example i just gave where the
transformation is flipping around this
line
v1 the vector 1 2 is an eigenvector of
our transformation
so v so 1 2
is
an eigenvector
eigenvector and its corresponding
eigenvalue is 1. so
eigenvalue
eigenvalue is 1.
this guy is also an eigenvector the
vector 2 minus 1 he's also an
eigenvector
a very fancy word but all it means is a
vector that's just scaled up by a
transformation it doesn't get changed in
any more meaningful way than just a
scaling factor and its corresponding
eigenvalue
eigenvalue is -1
if this transformation i don't know what
its transformation matrix is i forgot
what it was we actually figured it out a
while ago
if this transformation matrix
this transformation can be represented
as a matrix vector product and it should
be it's a linear transformation
then any v that satisfies
the transformation of
i'll say transformation of v is equal to
lambda v
which is also would be you know the
transformation of you just be a times v
a times v
these are also called eigenvectors of a
because a is just really the matrix
representation of the transformation
so in this case this would be an
eigenvector
of a
and this would be the eigenvalue
associated with the eigenvector
eigenvalue associated with the
eigenvector so if you give me a matrix
it represents some linear transformation
you can also figure these things out now
the next video we're actually going to
figure out a way to figure these things
out but i want what i want you to
appreciate in this video is that you
know
it's easy to say oh you know the vectors
that don't get changed much but i want
you to understand what that means they
literally just get scaled up or maybe
they get reversed but they don't their
direction or the lines they span
fundamentally don't change and the
reason why they're interesting for us is
that they well one of the reasons why
they're interesting for us is that they
make for interesting basis vectors basis
vectors whose matrix transformation
matrices are maybe computationally more
similar
simpler or ones that make for better
coordinate systems